hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
section 12 of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding is titled
of the academical or skeptical
philosophy and in the three subsections
he is going to be exploring what kind of
skeptical
philosophy he wants to endorse and which
he wants to reject and he begins by
talking about this important
distinction that's going to be made
between two species of skepticism and so
he says there is a species of skepticism
antecedent all study and philosophy
which is much inculcated by Descartes
and others as a sovereign preservative
against error and precipitate judgment
it recommends a universal doubt and if
you know anything about Renee Descartes
discourse or his
meditations you're probably quite
familiar with this no notion of
hyperbolic or methodological doubt as
the place where you begin for philosophy
and Hume says you know we can not not
only doubt our former opinions and
principles but also are very faculties
of whose veracity we must assure
ourselves by a chain of reasoning
deduced from some original principle
which cannot be fallacious or deceitful
and Hume says that's kind of a
non-starter because you're not going to
find such a principle or at least you're
not going to find such a principle that
will meet the requirements of rational
inquiry like we see Descartes beginning
with and so he says you know there isn't
any such principle or if there was could
we advance A Step Beyond it by but by
use of the very faculties that we're
supposed to be using the Cartesian doubt
therefore were were it ever possible to
be attained by any human creature and
then in parentheses as it plainly has
not and parentheses would be entirely
incurable and no reasoning could ever
bring us to a state of assurance and
conviction on any subject so he's
rejecting Cartesian doubt but he does
say well you know this can actually be
useful when moderate uh it can be
understood in a very reasonable sense
and is a necessary preparative to the
study of philosophy why because it
allows us to preserve proper
impartiality in our judgment and to wean
our mind from those prejudices which we
might have imbibed from education or
rash opinion so he's saying you know the
Cartesian method if we take out this
requirement of doubting everything and
then building everything up on
indubitable principles it can actually
be quite quite helpful so you know
skepticism antecedent to study and
philosophy limited endorsement there and
then Hume says
there is another species of skepticism
consequent so following
science and inquiry and is this the same
thing or different than study and
philosophy I mean I think these using
these more or less synonymous so we have
you know what we do before what we do
after and you know after we've actually
learned something by study and
philosophy or science and inquiry like
what has been going on in the entire
work of the inquiry right so he says
that um this is we suppose either the
absolute fallaciousness of mental
faculty is because we experience that
our mental faculties aren't really any
good or they're unfitnessed to reach any
fixed determination even our very senses
are brought into dispute by a certain
kind of philosophers and the maxims that
is the ways in which we regulate are
common life are subjected to the same
doubt as the most profound principles or
conclusions of metaphysics and Theology
and so you know this is essentially
hume's program but he wants to do it
again in a moderate way so we we turn to
looking at skepticism about the senses
you know sight hearing touch all of
these things that we kind of take for
granted and humor is actually going to
say something quite startling here he
says I need not insist on the more trite
topics employed by Skeptics in all ages
against the evidence of sense so two
things there evidence of sense right so
we're not saying that the senses
themselves are you know at bottom
totally unreliable we're just saying
yeah a lot of times we get things messed
up and notice that he is saying at his
time in the 18th century yeah yeah we've
we've heard enough of this stuff I mean
history of ideas is full of these sorts
of things let me give you a few examples
the imperfection and fallaciousness of
our occasions on numberless occasions uh
the Crooked appearance of an ore in
water right so refraction the various
aspects of objects according to their
different distances Descartes likes this
thing about you know the sun is actually
quite large but we see it as this tiny
dot he also talks about the square tower
that looks round at a distance the
double images which arise from pressing
one eye and many other appearances of
like nature and so Hume says we all know
these right what do these go to prove to
us what do they actually tell us they
just show us that we need to pay
attention to the senses the senses alone
are not implicitly to be dependent on
but we must correct their evidence by
reason and considerations derived from
the nature of the medium distance of the
object
etc etc right so you know to use the sun
example uh the sun is not a you know
glowing yellow disc that's about this
big up in the sky it's actually a
gigantic body so we use reasoning to
figure that out but there are as Hume is
going to say more profound arguments of
the senses and these admit of not so
easiest solution in fact they may not
have a complete solution all together
and so this is where Hume talks about
this natural instinct to propose faith
in our senses you know from the
beginning of our being we are taking
incense information and we are assuming
that actually corresponds to something
he actually says that even the animal
creation is governed by a like opinion
so it's not just human beings it's also
all the rest of animal life and so far
as it is you know registering things
that it takes to be outside of itself
and he says that you know we do this
without any reasoning even before the
use of reason we always suppose an
external Universe which depends not on
our perception so we we suppose a
universe outside of ourselves as objects
and notice what he says there that
depends not on our perception so I mean
strictly speaking if I wanted to confine
myself only to what I perceive in the
moment perhaps only the room that I'm
filming this in right now actually
exists because that's all that I'm
sensing right so and you know if you're
watching this or listening to it then
perhaps and you really focus on it maybe
that's all that exists right but we
don't we don't think of it that way we
actually have this naive faith that no
no there's like if I go beyond this
there's you know a hallway and rooms and
a larger world it's part of a building
and then part of a city and we could go
on and on and on so we have this Natural
Instinct that leads us to trust in our
senses opposing a natural universe and
going further
we trust that our perceptions or
representations
are veritical in the sense that they
refer to things outside of ourself he
says that we suppose the very images
presented by the senses to be the
external objects and we never entertain
any suspicion that the one or nothing
but representations of the other but if
we actually start doing philosophy and
thinking these things through what I see
with my eyes I say oh I see the lights
out there but what I'm actually
registering is an idea or a perception
or whatever which is in my mind in my
Consciousness not necessarily that thing
that I think is out there to which it
corresponds so he says the very table
which we see white and which we feel
hard is believed to exist independent of
our perception and to be something
external to our mind to you which
perceives it he says our presence
bestows not being on it our absence does
not annihilate it so again world of
objects but now we can think about
individual objects and our perceptions
of them right and he goes out and he
says
this Universal and primary opinion of
all human beings is destroyed by the
slightest philosophy which teaches us
that nothing can ever be present to the
mind but an image or a perception and
that the senses are only the inlets
through which these images are conveyed
without being able to produce any
immediate intercourse between the mind
and the object outside of ourselves the
table we see seems to diminish as we
move away from it right but the real
table
doesn't change at all
so there's a disconnect between our
perceptions or images in our
Consciousness our mind and what is
supposed to be out there and he says
that um
these are the obvious dictates of reason
and no man who reflects ever doubted
that the existences we consider when we
say this house and that tree are nothing
but Perceptions in the mind and fleeting
copies or representations of other
existences which remain uniform and
independent but you know this is not too
bad right because we still do have
external objects we're just like well
our senses kind of that you know they
don't deceive us as such like totally
get things wrong but they do
let's say allow us to mislead ourselves
about these these uh external objects
and then he says something quite
interesting right
um
he says uh how do we how do we know
whether the perceptions of the senses
are produced by external objects
resembling them how would we resolve
this well we would have to rely on
experience but here experience is not
helpful because we're using experience
to make sense out of experience right
experience it is and must be entirely
silent he says we don't have any reason
to to actually think from a rational
perspective that there are external
objects and then he says well maybe you
have recourse to the veracity of the
Supreme Being who's he talking about
here once again Renee Descartes who does
in fact do this in the meditations and
in the discourse right so he says the
recourse to the veracity of the Supreme
Being in order to prove the veracity the
truthfulness of our senses is making a
weird circuit if God's veracity we're
concerned in this matter our senses
would be entirely infallible because
it's not possible he can can ever
deceive right so that's a problem and
then he says here's another issue if the
external world is called into question
we're going to be at a loss to find
arguments by which we can prove the
existence of that being or any
attributes so again a rejection of
cartesianism and of the rationalism you
could say that
um is involved there
Hume is going to deepen the problem by
bringing up the issue of primary and
secondary qualities something that you
see in both the rationalist and the
empiricist side of early modern
philosophy so we should remind ourselves
well what what is this distinction
between primary and secondary qualities
so secondary qualities are things that
we think are there in the object but
they're not really there in the object
they're produced in our minds by how our
senses take in that object so the yellow
of this book is a matter we know from
the science of you know light waves
radiation that is being registered by
the the eye and then it's actually
taking like signals and turning it into
electrical impulses which go through the
optic nerve go into the brain the brain
actually puts together all of this stuff
in you know some rather still mysterious
way and we get you know yellow and we
also get you know hard on on this side
and the pages themselves being soft and
smooth these are
these are qualities that are not
actually there and the object as such
they're there in my interaction with the
object so what is actually there well
you know we would say things like shape
and form and structure and you know
maybe if we get down to like chemical
things the interactions between chemical
uh compounds and electrical impulses all
these sorts of things we'd say are
actually primer so the primary is the
basis for the secondary and you know
people like Locke and Descartes made
strong distinctions between these two
kinds of properties so he says
it's universally Allowed by modern
inquirers all the sensible qualities of
objects like hard soft hot cold white
black are merely secondary and they
don't exist in the objects they are
perceptions of the mind without any
external archetype or model which they
represent and then here's The Clincher
Hume says well okay let's assume that's
the case
if that's true secondary qualities it
must also follow with regard to the
supposed primary qualities of extension
and solidity and we could actually
extend this to other supposed primary
qualities like number shape or things
like that he says Where do we actually
get our idea of extension from from the
senses of sight and feeling we can say
the same thing about solidity except
that's more a matter of feeling this is
just as dependent on our way of
perceiving things through
representations as are the secondary
qualities so primary qualities are just
as we could say doubtful just as dubious
right and then he says well maybe
there's another way in which we get our
mind around these he says nothing can
save us from this conclusion but
asserting that the ideas of those
primary qualities are attained by
abstraction okay that's that's a common
way of dealing with that and he says if
we examine that we're going to find that
unintelligible and on and absurd an
extension that is neither tangible nor
visible can't possibly be conceived
you're playing with words right he says
let any man try to conceive a triangle
in general
which is neither isosceles isosceles nor
scalenum nor has any particular length
or proportion of sides then he will soon
perceive
the absurdity of all the Scholastic
Notions with regard to abstraction and
general ideas so he's saying well this
is not actually going to work and so
we're in kind of a bind here right and
he concludes this at the end of part one
says the first philosophical objection
to the evidence of the sense or the
opinion of external existence consists
in this that's such an opinion if rested
on natural instinct is contrary to
reason so we've got a we've got a clash
between what reason as humans just
reasoned out tells us in this sort of
primary Natural Instinct that leads us
to think things that are against reason
or he says if referred to reason it's
contrary to the Natural Instinct and at
the same time carries no rational
evidence to convince an impartial
inquiry so that that's a first
philosophical objection right the the
second objection he says goes further
and represents this opinion as contrary
to reason at least if it be a principle
of reason that all sensible qualities
are in the mind not in the object
take matter take away from matter all of
its intelligible qualities primary and
secondary you in a manner annihilate it
and leave only a certain unknown and
inexplicable something as the cause of
our perception and he says Ah we don't
want to go down that route that would be
like the route of you know one of him's
predecessors Berkeley but you can also
see something like this in line we don't
really know what substance is right and
him wants to say well maybe that's going
a little too far right but we certainly
have good reasons human thanks to be
rather skeptical about what it is that
our senses do in fact purport
to tell us